[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفتي اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وسط خلافات محتدمه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قوته
من الدعم السريع تصل الى العاصمه الخرطوم
بعد انتشارها في محيط مطار مروي ومصدر في
الجيش يؤكد للجزيره انتشار قوته بكثافه في
محيط المطار وان الامور تتصاعد بينما تدعو
قوى مدنيه لتغليف صوت العقل بايدن يقول ان
تحقيقا شاملا على وشك الانتهاء بشان ازمه
تسريبات وثائق البنساجون وسائل اعلام
الامريكيه تكشف ان الشاب الامريكيا يعمل
بقاعده عسكريه هو المسؤول عن التسريب
بينما نشرت نيور تايمز وثائقه جديده تشمل
معلومات بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا وتقديم
الصين مساعدات عسكريه كبيره لروسيا كوريا
الشماليه تطلق صاروخا بارستيا جديدا يعمل
بالوقود الصلب باتجاه بحر اليابان وطوكيو
تحتج وتطلب من السكان دخول الملجا اواشنطن
تعتبر التجربه الصاروخيه انتهاكها لقرارات
مجلس الامن بينما دعت بيجيل للتوقف عن دفع
الوضع في شبه جزيره الكوريه نحو المواجهه
ناشطون الفلسطينيون يدشنون حمله الكترونيه
للمطالبه بالافراج عن الاسير والقياده
بحركه الجهاد الاسلامي خضر عدنان والذي
يواصل اضرابه المفتوح عن الطعام لليوم
الثامن والستين على التوالي في سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في ظروف صحيه صعبه
للغايه وسط تحذيرات من تصاعدي ومن تضاعف
المخاطر على حياته الى اللقاء